>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
[ Silence ]
>> So, today I have a pleasure of
introducing you to Ree Drummond.
Many of you I'm sure know
her as the Pioneer Woman AKA.
PW AKA P-Dub.
[Applause] She is the force behind
a blog about her life, her family,
her cooking but she's really nothing
short of a sensation as millions
of readers know who every month log
on to find out what she's feeding
or teaching the punks
as she calls her kids.
What her Basset Hound
Charlie might be up to.
What her husband looks like
today in his wranglers and chaps.
Of course when a cake recipe
might look like if you decided
to take 53 photos of
every step of the process.
One of my favorite recent recipes
of hers, because I'm a food lover
and a cook myself, is for
something recently she put
up that she simply calls, the bread.
You haven't seen it,
it's a loaf bread.
It's 2 sticks of butter and it's
a little time in the broiler
and if you are able to read this
recipe and not go to the store
and buy a loaf of French bread and
2 sticks of butter and run home
to your broiler, then you need
to have your pulse checked.
Now, Drummond was raised
in Oklahoma but she got
out as soon as she could.
She fled to LA for college.
And then she planned to go
to Chicago for law school
but then she met her Marlboro
man on a trip back home.
She ended up living on a
4th generation cattle ranch.
And now, in addition to the
blog, she has her first cookbook,
"The Pioneer Woman Cooks" which
made it all the way to the top
of amazon.com's cookbook rating
by the virtue of pre-orders alone
and her series on the
blog from Black Heels
to Tractor Wheels is also
headed for publication
and she's also sold
the movie rights.
So, ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome, Ree Drummonds.
[ Applause ]
>> I was okay until he said this
is being videotaped would wind
up in the archives of the Library
of Congress, so I gotta go, bye.
[Laughter] It's so nice to see you
all here and it's such an honor
to be here in Washington.
I was walking through
the tent just--
I almost choked up a
couple of times that I--
just kind of the pride I
felt just seeing the kids.
I wake up often with cows on my
porch that don't belong there
and the things that come from cows.
I won't go into detail but
that's sort of a weekly,
weekly struggle is cleaning
the manure off my porch.
And isn't this a classy
presentation?
[Laughter].
I've already talked about
sweat and manure and--
what else can I talk about?
But, I'm gonna-- by virtue
the fact that I'm a blogger.
You know, I think a blogger
is like the complete opp-- -
>> [Inaudible] with you or your
blog or your cookbook or anything
but I'm interested
in hearing about it.
So, I'd like to hear a little bit
about your cookbook
and how it got started.
>> Okay. I-- like I said, I
started my personal blog in 2006.
It was on a whim.
I have 4 children.
My baby had just been
weaned which always sounds
like a livestock term to me.
I've weaned my baby.
And my husband had
taken all the kids
to work cattle with him for the day.
So, I found myself in this house and
I just wondered over to the computer
and thought, "I'm gonna
start one those blog things."
In 2006, blogs were definitely
around but they weren't
as prevalent obviously
as they are now.
I thought a blog was a free website.
I had no idea it involved
interaction from readers.
But I thought it would
be a good way for me
to share photos with my mother.
And I've posted a few
photos of my kids.
I had one reader.
It was my mother, in fact.
And then I started posting
stories from my pasts,
kind of the embarrassing stories
that I would whip out at you know,
parties or get-togethers
with friends.
Well, this wasn't necessarily
embarrassing but when I was
in Los Angeles, I ran
into James Garner
in an elevator and he kissed me.
So, I always like to say, I kissed
James Garner in an elevator.
And Gary Coleman, rest his soul,
I bumped into him when I was young
and starstruck when I just moved
to Los Angeles as an 18-year-old.
I saw him in Benihana
and he was eating.
And I just though, why wouldn't
anybody want a freckled redhead
to walk up to them in Benihana
and ask for their autographs.
So, I asked for Gary
Coleman's autograph
and he seemed a little bit--
he kinda wanted to eat his
meal which you can understand
but he said, "Well,
give me your address
and I'll send you a fan kit."
So, I leaned down to
write my address
and I spilled a steaming
hot pot of tea in his lap.
[Laughter] And it was--
steam was rising
from his khakis and
so I got that out.
There was a lot I needed
to purge my solo.
So, I was posting these embarrassing
stories and then I moved
into rural life, country life.
And I was a real fish out of
water as I repeat over and over
when I moved to the country.
I grew up on a golf course, so I
knew nothing about saddling a horse,
finding livestock in your yards.
So, when I married my
husband, it was all new to me.
So then, my blog sort of took
the direction of recording,
chronicling my daily adjustment
and transition to country life.
About 8 months into my blog, I
was getting ready to cook a steak
and I thought, "Well, I blog about
every other darn thing in my life,
you know, my children,
dogs, my thoughts."
So, I took my camera to the
kitchen and I took photos
of myself cooking the steak.
Everything from seasoning it
to flipping it on the grill pan
on my stove, and I literally was
down there with my camera like this
and I have the tongs like this.
And I just wrote a post
called how to cook a steak.
I thought, "Well, that's
the end of my blog."
You know, "Who wants to see that?"
But I wound up posting
about 17 photos
of this steak-grilling process
and there was an immediate
positive response.
And what I learned-- I kept
doing recipes like that.
I did my lasagna and then I did
my chocolate cake and I kept kind
of posting the recipes that I cooked
within the context of
my life on the ranch.
And what I learned was
that a lot of people--
whether they knew how
to cook or not already,
they appreciated the assurance
not just of the final photo
but of the processed
shots along the way.
And I was always a cookbook
buyer that had to have a photo
of the finished dish at least.
And often, the finished photo is
styled and perfect and lovely.
So, my finished photos are--
you know, just there's my
steak on the plate, you know.
So, really, the cooking section
of my site started growing
and the cookbook-- gosh,
this is a long answer.
I promised not to do this
with future questions.
The cookbook came about
probably a year and a half later
and it really is just a natural
extension of my cooking section.
I wanted it to be the same tone,
the same step by step
format, the same weirdness.
I mean, if I make a mistake
midway, I'm not gonna go back
and start the recipe over so, you
know, I just sorta pay no attention
to that mistake I just made and.
I think many readers appreciate just
the assurance that if I can do this,
they can do it too,
because I'm not a chef.
I'm not-- I wasn't trained
in a culinary school so.
>> I like to know more about the
lodge and what its future may hold
and would it involve anything
such as a bed and breakfast?
>> Bed and breakfast?
Well, we have a guest
house on our ranch.
Many who've read my site for
a while know about the lodge.
It was an old guest house and it's
where my husband lived when we met.
And when I started writing this
romantic Green Acres meets Harlequin
Romance serial on my site, a lot
of it took place in the lodge.
Well, a couple of years
ago-- 2 and a half years ago,
it was termite infested
and the electric was shut,
the plumbing was shut, so we were
very, very close to tearing it down.
And we just decided to
renovate it instead.
[Laughter] It was kind of like
riding a horse into a burning barn.
We just-- you know, we didn't know
what we were getting ourselves into
and it turned into a
really big project.
But since I'm a blogger,
I thought, "Perfect.
I'll blog about it."
So, I posted at least weekly
updates of the lodge project
and I actually had readers kind
of help me decide some
materials and some colors.
And so, the lodge now-- we
mostly use it for family
and friend get-togethers.
But I've actually used
it several times
to have blogging get-togethers.
>> Sometimes, I'll invite
a guest food blogger.
I don't know if many
of you might have heard
of Smitten Kitchen, Bakerella.
Bakerella has a new
book out, it's great.
And then I invite readers from
both of our audiences to come and--
so, it's kind of fun to have it.
As far as a bed and breakfast,
I don't have any plans to do
that because then I'd have to wash
the sheets on a schedule and I sort
of like being more free,
otherwise known as lazy,
[Laughter] about getting the
beds made so, maybe someday.
Yeah?
>> Hi.
>> Glad you're here.
>> Thank you.
>> One thing I love about your blog
and the cookbook is the art work.
Who does that?
Where is that from?
I just wanna be heard
a little bit about it?
>> Now, across the top or the
little ones at the bottom?
>> Yeah, the top and like the
cow girls that are in and like,
the book you have beautiful
flowers and--
>> Well, I'll tell you.
It's not a trade secret.
[Laughter]
>> Yeah.
>> Well, there's-- there
are several answers.
I have an artist, called,
named Maia Chavez Larkin
and she actually did some custom
illustrations of my children.
So the ones of the little cowgirls
and cowboys, those were custom made.
Now, the art that's
in my site banner
that I changed once a month
is nothing but Dover clipart.
Yeah, it's Dover-- if
you Google Dover clipart,
they have probably 50 just paperback
books with a CD in the back.
And they have vintage
flowers, vintage images
and I just-- I love the style.
>> It's beautiful.
>> And I am not an artist so I
couldn't draw a flower and if I did,
I would have no website,
because people would be
like, "What an amateur."
[Laughter]
>> It looks great.
>> Thank you.
Yes?
>> Hi.
>> As a former horrible cook, I like
to say thank you for your cookbook.
>> Oh, thank you.
>> Because all the pictures are
very helpful and as a current--
kinda alright cook, I have
a proposition for you.
Would you like to trade cooking
lessons for flying lessons?
[ Laughter ]
>> Are you aware that I hate to fly?
[Laughter]
>> I am. I could change your mind.
>> I just conquered a fear of flying
about a year ago, so--
so you're a pilot?
>> Yup.
>> Great.
>> I'll give you-- [Laughter].
I'll give you cooking
lessons with-- for nothing.
[Laughter] In exchange for nothing.
>> That's a really good deal.
Alright.
>> Where are you a pilot?
Where are you?
>> I'm based in Atlanta and
I had a trip up here and saw
that you're gonna be here so
I just happened to be here.
>> Ironically, if I
took flying lessons,
it would probably help my
fear knowing but it's a--
it a fear that was fostered by
living in the country for 10 years
and never going anywhere.
So--
>> Well, if you wanna change it.
I'm sure we could help you out.
>> E-mail me.
>> Okay. [Laughter]
>> You might be sorry you did that.
[ Laughter]
>> I'll write you before
my trips, and I'll be like,
"Are you sure these
things don't go down?"
>> I'm positive.
[Laughter] Alright, thank you.
>> Thanks.
[ Pause ]
>> Oops, I'll repeat your question.
>> Okay, first of all
thank you so much
for letting us in on a daily basis.
You are like my favorite
past time everyday.
>> Oh, thank you.
>> And my question for you
is, being an amateur blogger,
how do you keep the consistency?
You obviously have a million
other things going on.
How do you just keep it up?
So, [inaudible] keep your
readership up by being consistent?
>> How do I keep up my
blogging consistency?
>> Yeah, I mean you have
posts several times a day
and it always amazes me.
>> Oh, some are more quality
than others, but, well,
it helps that I love blogging.
And it also helps that I have
blogged from almost 5 years.
And it's amazing-- when I looked
back at my writing in 2006
in the early days-- and I
don't do that very often,
I'm amazed at how much less
polished and sophisticated--
not that my writing is all
that sophisticated now,
that I think anything you do
for an extended period of time
and anything you do regularly,
you're going to improve
and not only will you improve
but it will become easier for you
and blogging for me is easy.
I can-- I'm able to sort of sit
down at the computer and let it flow
and I'm anyone who's having trouble
kind of getting into the swing
of blogging that wants to blog, I
always say blog, just blog daily.
And there are gonna be days when
you wake up and say, I have nothing
to say to the world and that
actually happened to me once.
In September of 2007, I woke up
and I had the most raging case
of writer's block and I'd
never experienced it before
and I had nothing write.
And I remembered a chapter
that I had written of a book
that I decided not to
write-- did that make sense?
But it began with the
night I met my husband.
And it was called, The
Night I Met Marlboro Man.
So, since I had nothing to say
that day, I just whipped that out
and put it on my website and that
was the first chapter Black Heels
to Tractor Wheels.
And it turned into a
45-chapter serial online.
And it was-- 'cause I didn't
give in to the writer's block,
I didn't write but I
got something up anyway.
So, just stick with it.
You'd be amazed a year from now
how much easier blogging is.
>> Thank you.
>> And don't be afraid to
just embarrass yourself.
[Laughter] Some days when I
didn't have anything to write,
I would record myself
singing Ethel Merman's songs.
There's no business
like show business.
Raise your hand if you
know who Ethel Merman is.
[Applause].
>> Not very many people.
[Laughter] So, most of you are
basically sitting there going what
is she doing?
[Laughter] Yes?
>> I'm just wondering if your
kids actually see the blog
and how did they deal with the
pictures and everything else--
like, how do they feel about it?
>> Well, it sort of like that you
know, I've been doing it for so long
and have been taking
pictures of them for so long
that they really don't know
any-- they're prisoners.
[Laughter] Basically,
is what I'm saying.
My boys are 7-- at
how old are my boys?
Eight and 6, I have to
think about it sometimes.
And they could care less about
computers, so they-- they really--
they know I have a blog and
they know I have a cookbook
but they don't check in.
My daughters are 13 and 11,
so they're becoming more
interested in reading.
And fortunately while
there have been moments,
I can't really think
of any examples.
My content is pretty
family friendly.
I mean, there are some things
that children might find boring
that I don't have to worry that
if my girls pulled up my website,
they would come across
the F-bomb or you know--
>> But is there anything--
is there anything
that they would rather you haven't
shared like is there anything
that they like, "No
ma, don't do this?"
>> You know, not yet.
But I'm-- I mean-- you know,
I'm gonna just play it
by ear and not realm.
I can't imagine that I'll say,
"Stand there and look happy."
So, we'll just see.
So far, they've sort
of have fun with it.
Now, that is the common
question I get about my husband.
Has there ever been
anything that I've posted
that he's had a problem with.
And the answer is no, unless-- the
only time he's ever had a problem is
when I've gotten an
agricultural fact incorrect.
[Laughter] And then he
can't sleep for days.
I mean, he's just-- he'll be tossing
and turning and I'll be like,
"Are you still worried about that?"
And he'd be like, "It's
a steer not a cow."
So, generally it's gone pretty well.
>> As a beneficiary, I just like to
thank you for the cinnamon rolls.
[Laughter]
>> Oh, thank you.
That's probably my favorite recipe
of mine so I appreciate that.
Thank you.
They're nonfat.
[Laughter] Yes?
>> Hi, do you have any more details
on the possible movie version
of Black Heels to Tractor Wheels?
>> Possible movie version
of Black Heels--
and that's another thing when I
was referencing these extraordinary
thing developments
that have taken place.
It's probably going to move forward
that the thing that attracted me
about a possible movie version of
the love story is that first of all,
it was the gals who
did Julie and Julia,
Sony Pictures and they're all women.
So I think they would sorta get,
you know, the fizzy, in love things.
And I think they were also
interested in the angle that might--
as I was falling in love
with my cowboy husband,
my parents' marriage
was falling apart.
And I chronicled that both
on my site and in my book.
Boy, I'm sorry.
I didn't mean to depress everybody.
But the other thing that feels to me
about a possible movie is I
don't really have to do any work.
So, but I-- it'll be fun.
We'll just kinda see what happens.
>> So will you get to like give
input on the screenplay at all?
>> I think-- I don't think
I have official you know--
I don't think I can
mix anything officially
but I think they will
naturally, probably be interested
in a little input from me so.
>> Very cool.
>> For instance, I thought
Elle MacPherson should play me.
[Laughter] But they haven't
returned that e-mail.
Yes?
>> Hi.
>> I'm so glad you're here.
>> Thank you.
>> And sort of my boyfriend
said, "Oh, that pioneer woman
that I tell you about that I have
my cookbook laying in the kitchen."
He's like, "Oh, tell
her I love her salsa."
So, he wanted me to tell you that.
He loves the salsa.
>> I love that salsa, too.
Thank you.
>> And I just had one sort of
question and one other comment.
I guess my comment is one of the
things I love about your site--
and I just said that you know I
guess 'cause I have never have time
to leave a comment or anything.
I love checking it to see the
wonderful pictures that you put
up of the country because
I'm an east coast city girl
and I work downtown here
in DC and I had never seen
such great pictures I guess of--
>> Oh, thank you.
>> Way out there, where you just--
it's amazing to me that you look out
and see nothing 'cause if you've
lived in the city your whole life,
you'd never have gotten a
chance to see things like that
so that's really cool
to see everyday.
And I guess I just had a question
of whether you're planning
on writing another cookbook?
>> I am doing another cookbook.
It'll be a little while
before it's out.
I'm gonna do the Black Heels.
It'll be out in February and then
I have a Charlie children's book
coming out in the middle
of next year which is sort
of an illustrated version
of Charlie, my Basset Hound
and his short-legged plight.
And how he thinks he's a cow
dog that he's really of no use
to anybody except just comic relief.
So, but the cookbook will probably
be sometime in the following year.
So-- but as far as the wide
open spaces, I had to laugh
because when I first arrived today,
the crowd was a little more thin
and of course I thought
it was completely packed.
And then the gal who's
showing me around said, "Well,
like the crowds is
gonna get real heavy.
It's really light right now."
I had to laugh because, you know,
one other person is a big crowd
in my daily life so you can imagine
what an unusual sight this is but--
and I appreciate that.
I think that's one thing that
does appeal to city dwellers
about my blog is just a slice
of American life that is
so isolated and undeveloped.
So, thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> Yes.
>> Hi. I'm a librarian
from Gulf Shores,
Alabama came here primarily one
of the reasons was to see you.
>> Oh, thank you.
>> I wanna know how is Kitty
Kitty, still good, I hope.
>> Kitty Kitty is good.
She's-- she thinks she's a dog.
>> Because we had a similar
situation with my friend
from taking their Kitty Kitty to the
vet who went from Milo to being Sue.
>> I have-- we have a
stray kitten and I blogged
about this new darling little girl
kitten that we had and people said,
"That's looks like a male"
and I insisted for a week
that it was a female kitten and
it was in fact a male kitten.
So, I had-- I talked
about embarrassing myself.
>> But my real serious question
is, do you do all the content
for your homeschooling tab?
>> No.
>> 'Cause sometimes when
I see things about games
or learning tools, I wonder
if it's from other people.
>> I have 2 contributors on--
>> Thank you.
>> The homeschooling section.
The print is small but it
says at the top of the post,
posted by Heather Sanders,
posted by Kristen Chase.
>> I was interested
'cause we have a lot
of homeschoolers come
to the library.
>> Yeah.
>> Great.
>> I-- I'm quick to recognize
my own limitations and I notice
that I had only been able to
post on the homeschooling section
about once a week so I could either
homeschool my children and post
on the homeschool section.
>> Sure.
>> So, I was happy to take
on some contributors there.
>> Very good.
>> Hi.
>> Can you hear me--
ah there you go.
So, most of single ladies
in the audience would love
to know where cowboy Josh is?
[ Laughter ]
>> Cowboy Josh is like
the eye candy of--
the single eye candy on my blog.
He's our cowboy.
He's still very single.
Cowboy Josh wants children so
anyone who's not interested
in having children need not apply.
[Laughter] He would
even take the children.
He says, "I'll take the children
first and then I'll find a woman,"
and I'm like, "Josh, do
you know how this works?"
[Laughter] So, but he's good.
He's such a great guy.
>> And my other question
was, in all of the chaos
of what's become your
life here recently,
how do you personally find balance.
Is it through blogging or raising
your kids or what is it internally
that you use to kinda stable
yourself and keep yourself grounded?
>> That's a good question.
Well, if you saw our
daily life on the ranch,
you wouldn't need to
out that question.
And the-- really the country is
what grounded me when I moved there.
You know, I had lived in Los Angeles
and it was sort of a frenzy type
of person and when I moved to
the country I really found--
it sounds so cheesy to say,
I found my inner peace.
But, you know I really found myself
in the country so I loved going out
and going places that I
love going home the most.
And our day, I mean-- you can't lose
your head when you have cow poop
on your porch first
thing in the morning.
And there's no one to clean
it up but me, you know.
So, I found-- I find my
center in cow manure.
Is what I'm saying.
[Laughter] Yes.
>> Hi. Thank you so much for coming.
>> Thank you.
>> I have a question.
I work a little bit into IT and
so, your blog is always so polished
and I know that you're busy with the
cattle ranch and the homeschooling
and the photography and everything.
How many-- do you-- how many-- do
you have any people helping you
out with all the ad support
and the IT support like behind
such a big site that you have?
Like I know-- like how
many people do you have
like working with you on it?
>> Definitely, well when I started
my blog in 2006, I used Blogger.
You know?
>> Yeah.
>> My address was
pioneerwoman.blogspot.com
for about 6 months.
And then I moved to TypePad.
Those are both free online
blogging software platforms.
So, I did it all myself then.
And then Heather Sanders who is one
of my homeschool contributors
now helped me designed a custom,
WordPress site.
But now, with my-- you might have
noticed, I redesigned my site
in July, launched a redesigned.
>> It looks great.
>> Oh, thank you.
It took a long time
because I-- some--
I'm not meticulous in
any aspect of my life.
You just have to look in
my closet to realize that.
But with my site, I want
everything to be lined up and neat
and I want it to be pleasant.
But I have a team of-- not
a team, a guy and his friend
that are really good with
back-end WordPress stuff
and they pretty much
make sure it's secure.
My site was hacked about
a year ago and it was--
it was a nightmare for me.
I just hated the idea of it.
So, they make sure it's all
secure and working smoothly.
Thank you.
>> Thanks.
[ Pause ]
>> Hi.
>> Hi. I don't read blogs,
so I don't know anything
about your personal life except
what's in your wonderful cookbook
which I enjoyed very much.
>> Thank you.
>> Your recipes are so easy
to follow and delicious.
>> Thank you.
>> And, can just say
a little bit about--
you mentioned in the cookbook
about the mustangs and the horses
that you have in the ranch.
And where did they came
from and are they rescues?
>> Yes, we have-- we actually
are a family cattle ranch
and have always had just
cattle on the ranch.
We have a Cow/Calf Operation
and we also have yearlings.
And you know, not that I even
know what really that means
but I've heard my husband say
that we have cows on the ranch.
But in '03, we applied
for a contract to take
in sanctuary wild horses.
And it's through the Bureau
of Land Management, Wild Horse
and Burros Program, they're
overpopulated back west
and so they find landowners
who can take care of them.
And they-- so, we have a
ranch full of wild horses.
[Laughter] It's really wonderful.
We feed them in the winter time
but we just let them roam
free the rest of the year.
And they are wild animals.
You don't wanna make
one of them mad.
>> Thank you very much.
That's a great addition
to your book.
>> It's kinda been a fun diversion.
>> Hi.
>> Actually, I'm from Wyoming so I
understand the big wide open spaces,
but I wanted to ask you
about your Photoshop.
How do you-- did you have take
classes or training or how do you--
you have great Photoshop,
the actions and everything?
How did you come up with that?
>> Oh, thank you.
I bought my first camera 2
weeks after I started my blog.
I knew nothing about photography and
I took one lesson, private lesson
to kinda-- I don't even
know what an aperture was.
So, I've-- so I was
starting from scratch.
But I taught myself photography.
I posted a lot of really bad
pictures, took a lot of bad pictures
but you just learn as someone--
it's the same with blogging,
if you wanna learn photography
just take pictures everyday
and that's what I did.
And really, she's-- we got an
over time card going here so.
But, what I'm trying to impart
more than anything through my site
or through my cookbook
or even through my memoir
and I'll tell you why in a
second, is If I can do it,
you can do it whether it is cooking,
because cooking is not
rocket science or photography
or finding contentment in the middle
of nowhere which I was able to do.
So that's really what I'm trying
to pass on and I just wanted
to thank you all for being
here and your great questions
and it's great to see you.
Thank you.
[ Applause]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.